those who cannot remember the past are
condemned to repeat it Winston
Churchill's words were quoted by Vice
President of the European Parliament at
an opening of a memorial ceremony
organised by the Parliament to mark 70
years since the liberation of Auschwitz
lizet antiluminous contra communities
we've Digory sundays at ante de minas
contra no valio an opportunity clearly
there is a rise of the most virulent and
violent form of anti-semitism and
extremism of all kinds going on another
ceremony taking place in the Czech
Republic hosted by amongst others the
European Jewish Congress were shown live
on a big screen in our Parliament's in
our daily life on the streets wherever
anti-semitism racing center for we are
and whatever kind of fascist I'll arise
and appears we must stand up and say not
with us this is the best way to give an
example for children and their children
more than 6 million Jewish people were
exterminated during the Second World War
today has europe learn the lessons of
history